découvrez gilles verdez en femme mais
elle est pas mal du tout la verdez ah
ouais quand même
car si j'étais une femme serait sa forme
pierre besnard bouder de d'orsan gravats
qu'est l'île est devenue avec foot c'est
un compliment ou des arrêts magnifiques
c'est mon ami je laime donc je le prends
vraiment comme un compliment
et c'est grâce aux stylistes d'ailleurs
ce que j'ai vu les vidéos fanfan la
tulipe comme animateur gilles verdez
quand il parle on dirait qu'il a envie
de faire ses besoins
ouais ça peut pas réveiller un sentiment
d'urgence donc j'ai assez d'accord avec
ça ça et c'est voilà ça ne peut pas
attendre
quand je parle ça vient des tripes
cessez donc voilà c'est tripale donc
entièrement d'accord rien de mourir à
moi je kiffe la grande gueule de gilles
verdez continue comme ça promis je vais
essayer même si le niveau est faible à
côté moi j'essaie quand même mais c'est
pas facile quand vous avez gagné à côté
de vous vraiment en avoir pour mais bon
j'ai l'habitude et benjamin castaldi qui
cassent tf1 alors qu'il travaillait chez
eux
d'abord un jeu des casses pas
systématiquement et des personnes tout
court d'ailleurs
quand il est chaud si tu pourras me
dirons pas plus
c'est jamais très méchant il devrait
très bientôt graziella m busy quellier
de vesly est là que le cumul de gros
dans le qi
bon alors déjà vu ta phrase toi déjà que
tu dois pas avoir un appui exceptionnel
on pourrait faire une battle de guilers
il n'y a plus de roi en france mais il
ya encore un paquet de bouffon dont
gilles verdez pas mal pas mal pas mal
pas mal s'il y en a un qui se prend pour
un roi
c'est monsieur berne voilà moi je suis
un bouffon si vous voulez mais lui c'est
un roi et ne le reconnaît pas voilà
benjamin castaldi est ce que tu aimerais
pas avoir soit une chronique à toi une
émission sur ses 800 ans auparavant est
ce que ce serait pas le moment de
réfléchir
tu préfères sur la chaîne et ben j'ai
réfléchi régulièrement j'ai la chance d
à 2 présenté les tpe et leur dit ouvert
à tous
je vais faire un prime là il ya plein de
choses qui arrivent me rends je suis
très content chi va piano allant de
panneaux mais qui équivalent à mme
daneau vapiano backes qui venait valdano
et qui va savoir le panneau bref
l'équipe 2 euros très beau pseudo je
t'adore qui lit tu es ma préféré et de
loin adorable gentille et magnifique
sans toi tu es pembe n'aurait pas la
même saveur bonne nuit
bon alors là merci d'amour plus demande
le peuple
franchement merci beaucoup pour ton
soutien et d'ailleurs marti pour ce
genre de message parce que vraiment ça
me va droit au coeur
pourquoi vous jouez un rôle dans tpm p
alors ça c'est la question qu'on pose
souvent mais je ne joue pas un rôle dans
tpm p je ne suis pas un acteur je ne
suis pas leonardo dicaprio ni je ne sais
qui je fais ce que je peux en donnant
mes arguments mes sensations
ces tranches et ça plaît ou ça plaît pas
mais c'est moi même donc ya pas de rôle
dans tpm et je réponds toujours à la
question même si rim la pose parfois en
plateau non il n'y a pas de rôle à
nantes et m je suis moi-même voilà et si
au bout de toutes ces années je n'étais
pas moi
alexandrine au da luz alors qu'il y
avait deux villes y est l'une des plus
intéressantes de des pmp quand elle
parle à une vie riche en ligne offre non
c'est très gentil merci c'est un péno
mais mon plaisir
j'ai pas beaucoup de prise de parole
mais quand je parle j'essaye au minimum
de d'en faire quelque chose d'en
profiter et ça me fait vraiment plaisir
que tu m'envoies ce message quel terreau
vaillant on va les propos de répéter ce
type est vraiment intelligent labrecque
bref quelqu'un qu'il ya qui a su capter
a certainement le potentiel un teckel
énorme qu'est le mien alors ludivine
guenon guaino je préfère eu de nom parce
que c'est très possible ce tweet
franchement remettez nous bouder carla
qu'il est de veiller elle se sent
pousser des ailes
il faut arrêter la red bull alors écoute
ludivine guenon je vois pas de red bull
ni d'alcool soit que du caucase et en os
donc du coup je peux pas me sentir
pousser des ailes et merci pour bouder
car ces fonds c'est mon ami
et j'espère que la prochaine fois il
sera là pour remplacer et lui ne bois
pas de réduire notre nation vous
connaissez la reine des neiges jerricans
à du loft
ah oui ah oui c est énorme
quoique jour est normé et blague à part
je ressemble un peu à ma grand mère